I'm Janna Levin I'm the director of
Sciences at Pioneer works here in Red
Hook Brooklyn pioneer works as a center
for art and events and science it's
really just an open spirited place where
everybody brings to it what they have to
offer when I first came to Pioneer works
out as a scientist in residence and I
was finishing a book on black holes and
people couldn't really understand why I
would come to write a science book at
this art space where it was loud and
noisy and dusty and people were working
and exhibits were coming and going but
for me it was this perfect distraction
and I would be so inspired watching the
exhibits come and go and it really
helped me kind of find a tone and a pace
and a way to focus on my own seemingly
unrelated work so most of the time I
really undoing hardcore scientific
research anyway work is very theoretical
and very interested in black holes I'm
interested in gravitational waves the
shape of space-time whether extra
dimensions can trap dark energies it's
very abstract theoretical and
mathematical physics but then when I'm
writing I feel like it's something
totally different when I'm writing I'm
thinking about the pace and energy of a
story it's it's different but the
content is still usually very scientific
I love these conceptual ideas and the
eye and the sense in which they abstract
concepts can really shape and structure
a story